Meet a new person for a relationship, and once you shake it and know for yourself,
So suddenly realize "a moment ... I forgot his name." Why does this always happen?
And what is this forgetting about your brain?
The possibilities are that you will remember the person's face more than his name - our brain is designed
To know the details of the face. Brain scans show that brain cells are activated
Responding to see someone's face. But if we come to forget the name, it may come back
For what is known as the influence / factor of the baker. If I tell you that I am a baker, I give you
I know what I'm doing, how I spend my time, but if I tell you my name, Baker
Does not contain any useful mental link and the possibility of forgetting large. In the end random names
Do not carry specific information. And if your brain can not build a link
Between multiple pieces of information, especially things you already know or familiar with,
The probability of forgetting information is very large
It also will not help you think and concentrate in presenting yourself. This
It is known as the following Affinity Factor / Effect. Instead of following and listening to the person
The other one, your brain begins to focus on its routine or role (what you will say, how
Etc.) and we are simply not good at disseminating information at the same time we are trying to save new information
Our brain contains both long and short-term memory
But short-term memory, sometimes called "working memory," can not tolerate much
Of information, if not focused, they fade quickly
Finally, there is research suggesting that "drum beats" ... may simply be uninterested. Let's be frank - you may be at a party or gathering
You know you will not meet this person anywhere else, or in general you are not interested in forming
New relationships. Simply put, every Mazda interested in something is more likely
That your brain build new links. As a result people who like to build new relationships find them
They are interested and interested in Nadir who feel that they are using their memory and testing it.
So how do you improve your ability to remember names? Here are 7 clever tips to avoid
Forget the names in the new video that you can inspect by clicking on
Screen or link in the description. These tips were helpful to us! And
Register for more videos.